who's your beef with is it fauci is it
the nih is the who is it the schools
that basically
told you that you couldn't uh be a part
of it anymore is it big tech i mean i
want to get to the heart of the matter
here we're doing all these uh using all
these words that i'm gonna have to
google for the rest of my life what's
the damn bottom line who are you mad at
who [ __ ] up
you tell me i wanna know you look mad i
am mad because like the world has been
shut down
you know we're having these
conversations that's like i don't know
blah blah blah google this go to that
monoclonal blah blah i want to know the
bottom line here and i think a lot of
our viewers are like all right
i agree with you what can be done what
should be done what could have been done
differently did fauci [ __ ] up what
percentage did he [ __ ] up should he have
been fired years ago what's the bottom
line you know i'm saying like we can we
can do all this
talk in circles all that talk about tom
situate but like i just want bottom line
and from information i feel like for two
years we've just been running in circles
we got the doctor here who knows more
than anybody i'm looking for a bottom
line already what do you want
truth
but specifically what do you forget
about what i want what does the world
want to know what do you think the world
should know what do you think the world
wants to know how did this start what
should have been done
did fauci do the a good or bad job
and why are you being muzzled those
questions okay we've been focusing on
treatment
is it agreed
that the virus and the infection should
be treated in high-risk patients
yes
say the question again please is it
agreed that the virus and the infection
should be treated in high-risk patients
is there any resistance elderly people
immune compromised
very very heavy people who are smokers
under 40 that whole group yes okay so
don't you want information
rapidly available information to
patients and to doctors and to health
systems
to treat patients don't you want those
doctors and health systems to treat
patients early to prevent
hospitalization yes okay then where have
you been
where have you been
me yes where have i been yes the hell
doesn't matter where i've been because
it matters because it matters if you
haven't spoken up if you haven't stepped
out if you haven't done a lick of
anything then you're as complicit as
everybody else where have you been i
think that's a horrible unfair charge dr
mcculloch because what am i supposed to
do i'm living my life i'm 39 years old
this thing just happens out of nowhere
and you want me to quote unquote step up
what the hell do i know what the hell do
any of us know doesn't matter what you
know it matters what you want how would
i know what i want or how would anyone
know what they want when they've never
even heard of covid and uh and the world
and people are telling you hey you know
shut down for two weeks shut down for
two months i'm supposed to step up the
average versus to step up this is where
this is where we trust the signs this is
where we trust the medical field this is
where we trust people on stage with the
mics so for the average person the
quote-unquote step up i feel like is a
little inappropriate listen you're not
an average person you're sitting with
two cans on your ear and a lot of people
are listening to you you're not an
average person you just told me you
wanted to be treated
and i'm asking you what have you done
do you see the problem the media is as
complicit as the biomedical
pharmaceutical complex you're not
demanding treatment
and because you're not demanding
treatment and the average person is not
demanding treatment
what's happening is people are not being
treated by the virus people are coming
to me and saying dr mccullough save
america you're the one who published
these protocols you're the one to do
this do even more and what i'm telling
you if we don't have 330 million people
screaming for treatment whether it's
this virus or the next one i think they
were though no i think they were
i i think they were show me show me i i
think well okay fine let's go through it
and i'll process this like a lawyer and
i'm not even a lawyer
um
i think uh
number one a lot of people we had malona
dr malona
and when we had dr malone on it was i
think it was the next day after he was
on uh uh rogan and it just so happened
we didn't even know each other's
calendar but he apparently was doing the
tour he was on broken one day the next
day was with us right you're familiar
with dr robert malone yeah
and he was taken down immediately we had
judy mykovitz on at the peak i'm talking
two years ago i'm talking we had a run
in april of 2020 we had judy mykovitz on
first day gets couple million views boom
the video was taken down we had uh rfk
on come in and debate uh dershowitz on
the topic of vaccine mandates a year and
a half ago two years ago i'm not even
talking about in the last three months
year and a half ago in the thick of
things they came and they debated and
that video is still on on the internet
until today's couple million views
we've brought a lot of people on but uh
the challenge becomes the the ability
for
uh uh yesterday trump was on this uh
podcast folsom milk boys right and uh
the video trump says don't worry this
thing's not gonna stay on for too long
and next thing you know less than 24
hours gets five six million views and
it's taken down
and uh you know you he gets on hannity
to say this thing was taken out but i
told him it's gonna be taken now because
dana white wanted him to do this podcast
so
censorship you know what what i learned
from the outside here's what i've
learned as the non-expert i learned
that uh
that
the most powerful organization here when
it comes down to handling pandemic for
me to be able to seek the truth
is the one that's putting the muzzle on
the average a day-to-day person that
eventually says i'm not gonna post
anything why do we not have your video
today on youtube why is this not being
posted on youtube being posted on
spotify and apple and stitch and all the
other why not because we know the folks
at google are not going to let this
thing stay for another 24 hours it'll be
taken down we'll get a strike then we
can't do any podcast and we're shut down
for doing podcast for a week and then we
may get a second strike and we're
shutting down for three months then we
don't have a product to produce so
the the the policies by these major uh
social networks virtual governments
played a very big role where a lot of
average people like adam is talking
about felt they were muzzled so that i
realized they have the power number two
i don't think a person
needs to have as much power as they did
to control and intimidate the average
day-to-day person to dictate what kids
should wear in school as a mask or take
a vaccine like a fouchy does i think
giving too much power to one person is
very scary when it comes on to something
like this a president i get it there's
got to be a shot caller someone's got to
make the decision because we have
congress senate we have a
system judicial system legislative we
have a system that works you know even a
joe manchin his vote mattered so much
that the left was upset our system for
the most part works it's a decent system
that we have but fauci had a little too
much of a monopoly and everybody had to
look at him as the main at first if you
think about when the pandemic first got
started it wasn't just fouchy it was a
group of people that we heard it was
burks it was him it was a handful of
other people it wasn't just fauci fauci
fauci gradually he one by one by one got
rid of everybody else whether he did or
another way of getting away from it
and all of a sudden he's the guy he's
the voice you know he's the one that we
have to listen to and the hypocrisy
started coming out so the average day
person sitting there saying newsome is
saying you got to wear a mask and the
next day is that french laundry not
wearing a mask mayor rio grosso is
saying you got to wear a mask and he's
seen at a game not wearing a mask and he
says oh i don't breathe when i'm taking
pictures with people so the more and
more things like that happen people
started realizing maybe these guys are
just full of [ __ ] and then you sit there
and you wonder
what is uh what is uh really going on
behind closed doors yeah i was watching
the kennedy's documentary yesterday i've
interviewed a lot of guys on kennedy
whether it's his one of the secret
service agent and you know bolden uh who
was the first african-american secret
service agent whether it's jim jenkins
who was one of the four guys that held
his brain
uh 30 minutes after he died and oliver
stone does his documentary on john f
kennedy and you're sitting there
1963 what's today 2022 how many years is
that 60 years nearly 59 years later and
we have an idea what went on but for 75
years we can really do investigation to
dig into the numbers in the church and
even his own doctor who had been his own
doctor for years when interviewed in
1967 at the library was asked hey do you
still agree with the three shots that
was uh you know taken and what people
are saying with the warren report and he
says
i have no interest in commenting on that
what do you mean you have no interest in
commenting on that we kind of have an
idea what happened with john f kennedy's
assassination are we not going to find
that till 2000 and whatever the year is
that
pfizer put on a thing that we cannot
investigate this so the average person
sitting there saying honestly you guys
are so cocky doctors are very cocky i
know a lot of competitive people i'm in
a pretty competitive environment
football players are cocky
competitive everybody thinks they're
better basketball i gotta tell you the
doctor world oh my gosh you guys are
cocky holy moly everybody is so
competitive so what happens when you
guys are so competitive
the doctor world that i'm around and i
talk to experts like yourself
everybody is so damn worried about being
right and god forbid if you're wrong
once
that you stick to your ego of what is
right what is your right rather than
[ __ ] you may have been wrong once and
these doctors are afraid to freaking
debate each other because you're a
doctor you have to keep this facade of
how smart you are not saying you i'm
talking about as most of those doctors
so who gets to hit the average
day-to-day person
the bottom line is listen i'm not afraid
yeah it's obvious many people are it's
obvious that many people never spoke up
it's really obvious the media is afraid
the media is a big problem
a huge problem
now
who in the media wouldn't be interested
in an update on how to treat covet 19.
people in the media thousands of local
tv stations
why wouldn't they be interested in
giving update let's have a doctor on and
let's go over what you should do when
you get covet have you ever seen that
even once
think about the oblivion it didn't come
into the producers minds once to go over
an action plan when senior citizens get
coveted not once
think about that that is profound
that is profound
it didn't come up once in a single press
briefing for two years with the white
house task force one white house task
force two president one president two
vice president one vice president two
cnn fox cnbc msbc not once to have a
review on what we should do today when
we get treatment for covet 19 not once
what would happen if you had a debate
with
wait but i don't i don't know about that
what do you mean never came up once
i don't know if i agree with that
because i've watched
uh uh
even you you were on tucker i've watched
tucker bring doctors on who
recommended what to do and what's what
to prescribe and i've seen it even with
gupta making his own recommendation but
it's the recommendations of what the cd
i've seen a lot of that
uh uh
my look my own i have one concern here's
the only concern i have
very simple for me my entire outcome of
sitting down with you today we
appreciate you for coming out my only
outcome is
preventative for the next one that's all
i care about i don't like to be
manipulated i've never liked it i don't
like to be bullied i've never liked it i
don't like to be played games with i've
never liked it and all those three
things happened in the last two years
those three things create an emotion in
me that's not healthy i don't like it i
want to know what my options are as a
parent as a father as a ceo as an
entrepreneur as a content creator as an
american
what are my options
and i want to know we have the right
leaders in place that when the next
thing happens because of all this crisis
that's going on the world right now
ukraine russia putin's a big personality
jesus picked personality iran's got
their own thing that they're dealing
with
somebody gets upset and they create many
ways to want to hurt our lives through
bio or through cyber i want to know
we're prepared and i want to know how
what controls do i have
as an individual
when i deal with a doctor when i deal
with the people that are that's their
duty to do what they're doing on the
baby that's that's my biggest concern i
have now i tell you i totally disagree
with you we have not seen anything on
early treatment the minimum standards as
a citizen and a doctor that i would
expect is monthly updates
we've had nearly a million people die of
this illness we've had tens of millions
of hospitalizations
not enough not nearly enough monthly
updates full review
action plan billboards up in every city
how you get treatment every single
medical group emails outpatient
treatment centers people get sick with
code they should walk in
and they should be treated not even
close you're not even on first base you
haven't even gotten out of the dugout i
am telling you the next one that comes
we better have a completely different
plan we better have our marquee medical
institution step up i told tucker
carlson i said you know there's no mayo
clinic protocol to treat covet 19
there's no harvard protocol there's no
duke protocol
they haven't done a single thing they
haven't attempted to treat a single
patient to prevent hospitalization even
when they get in the hospital they don't
have any unique innovative advanced
protocols
it is a complete and total failure i
completely disagree with this and one of
the reasons why this has happened is the
media has been complicit in this the
median the media has had an oblivion to
early treatment and the people haven't
demanded it the people have been
slaughtered by this virus if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]